الارض تبتلع المباني في ثوان.
والصراخ ياتي من كل حد وصوب.
والابراج تخر صريعة على الارض.
البشر يفنون في لحظة واحدة.
والمدن تنتهي عن بكرة ابيها ما
بين عشية وضحاها. الارض تنشق
لتبتلع ما فوقها لينقلب عليها
سافلها والعالم كله مصدوم. ما
هذا الذي يجري? انه واحد حصد
الاف الارواح ومئات المباني وبعض
المدن. هل هو سخط الهي ام انه
ابتلاء اصاب به بعض الدول? لكن
هل هذا هو الزلزال الاخير? لا لا
لا. بل هناك زلازل مستقبلية قد
تحدث خلال الساعات القادمة. فما
هي الدول المعرضة لهذه الزلازل?
اذا فلتتابع هذا الفيديو. فقد
تكون دولتك معرضة لزلزال الساعات
او الايام القادمة. فمؤشرات
الكوارث الطبيعية غير مطمئنة.
لكن قبل ذلك مهلا هناك الكثير من
السوريين لا يزالون تحت الامطار.
وهم بحاجة الى المساعدة العاجلة
بسبب العجز في معدات الانقاذ.
فلا تتركوا اهل سوريا. هيا
فلنغرد جميعا باسم سوريا.
ولنناشد المجتمع الدولي بسرعة مد
يد الانسانية ولنترك خلافاتنا
وعشرين الف مصاب في لحظة واحدة.
نعم كل هذا في لحظة واحدة. نحن
نتحدث عن اسوأ كارثة طبيعية حدثت
في تاريخ تركيا وسوريا. زلزال
قوي ضرب جنوب شرقي تركيا وشمال
وغرب سوريا في الساعات الاولى من
صباح السادس من من هذا العام.
صرخات الاهالي تعم الارجاء. اسر
ابيدت عن بكرة ابيها. فهنا اب
تائه يبحث عن ابنته تحت الركاب.
عن اي الم نتحدث وهناك مئات
الاطفال تحت الانقاض منهم من تم
اخراجه بعد تسع وعشرين ساعة
ومنهم من لم يخرج بعد. الالاف
فارقوا الحياة قبل ان يعلموا ما
الذي حدث. عداد الضحايا لا
يتوقف. ها هو يتخطى سبعة الاف
قتيل وخمسة وثلاثين الف جريح في
تركيا وسوريا. الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان يعلن حالة الطوارئ
في المناطق المنكوبة. نعم لقد
خرج الامر عن السيطرة. وما الذي
باستطاعة اردوغان ان يفعله. لكن
الزعيم التركي عاد ليطمئن شعبه.
سنبني كل ما تدمر وسنعو كل من
خسر. هنا جرعة تحفيز في ذروة
الالم. ليتساءل اقرب الضحايا.
وهل ستعيد من رحل? يا لها من
نكسة انسانية في الطرف الاخر
للزلزال. الدفاع المدني التابع
للمعارضة السورية يصرخ اكثر من
الضحايا انفسهم. مئات العائلات
ما زالت تحت الانقاض. فهل من
مغيث? نرجو المساعدة. واذا كان
هذا حال فرق الانقاذ في سوريا
فكيف بحال الضحايا واقربائهم؟
انها كارثة لم تحدث لهم من قبل.
الدفاع المدني التابع للمعارضة
السورية لا يتوقف عن الصراخ.
وهنا يعلن قائلا ان اكثر من
ثلاثمائة وستين مبنى انهار بشكل
كامل واكثر من الف بشكل جزئي
فيما تصدعت الاف المباني الاخرى
في مناطق الشمال السوري جراء هذا
الزلزال. وها هو صوته مجددا
ليناشد جميع المنظمات الانسانية
والجهات الدولية بتقديم الدعم
المادي ومساعدة المنظمات التي
تستجيب لهذه الكارثة ومساعدة
ضحايا الزلزال بشكل عاجل. ونحن
كذلك نناشدهم يا هؤلاء فهل هناك
استجابة سريعة? هنا في تركيا
وحدها بلغ عدد قتلى الزلزال خمسة
الاف واربعمائة واربعة وثلاثين
شخصا والجرحى واحد وثلاثين الفا
وسبعمائة وسبعة وسبعين. وفقا
لاحدث احصاء اعلنه وزير الصحة
التركي فخر الدين اوجا. نعم انها
ثلاثمائة واثنتا عشرة هزة
ارتدادية اعقبت ذلك الزلزال.
الذي بلغت قوته سبعة فاصل سبع
درجات في مركز ولاية كهرمان مرعي
الجنوبي تركيا تسببت في صدع يمتد
طوله لما يزيد عن مائة كيلو متر
بين الصفيحة والصفيحة العربية.
اما في سوريا يا سادة فقد ارتفع
عدد ضحايا الزلزال في عموم سوريا
الى الف وثمانمائة واثنين
وثلاثين قتيلا وثلاثة الاف
وسبعمائة وخمسين مصابا في
محافظات حلب واللاذقية وحماة
وريف ادلب وطرطوس في حصيلة غير
نهائية. ليظهر هنا احد رجال
الدفاع المدني وهو يبكي بحسرة
بعد سماعه صوت امرأة وهي تصرخ
تحت الانقاض بمدينة ارمناز. يقول
يا الله يا الله والله ما بنعدو.
وهناك في تركيا. يطلق المواطنون
الاتراك دعوات عاجلة من اجل
ارسال الدعم الى مستشفى اديامان
جنوب وسط تركيا الذي يعج
بالضحايا ليعلن وزير الخارجية
التركي مولود جاويش اوغلو وصول
فرق انقاذ من ست وثلاثين دولة
الى تركيا للمشاركة في اعمال
البحث والانقاذ الزلزال. مؤكدا
ان اكثر من سبعين دولة عرضت
المساعدة. وماذا عن سوريا هل
سينظرون الى ضحاياها ايضا؟ لكن
ما لم كلمة حق بعيدا عن اي نزعة
سياسية فقد وجه اردوغان بانقاذ
السوري والتركي معا فكلهم بشر.
لكن هنا نعود لما هو غريب حقا.
فهذه المنطقة التي تعرضت لهذه
الكارثة لم يحدث فيها زلزال كبير
ولم تشهد هزات تحذيرية منذ اكثر
من مائتي عام. ولذلك كان مستوى
التأهب يتوقع ان يكون اقل من
منطقة اكثر اعتيادا على التعامل
مع الهزات الارضية. الزلزال عاد
مرة اخرى الى تركيا يوم الثلاثاء
السابع من فبراير اي بعد زلزال
غاز عنتاب بيوم واحد. لكنه كان
بقوة خمسة فاصل ستة درجة هز وسط
تركيا بحسب المركز الاوروبي لرصد
الزلازل. فهل هناك زلازل لاحقة
يا ترى? لنتريث قليلا. قبل ثلاثة
ايام من الزلزال كان الخبير
الهولندي والباحث في شؤون
الزلازل فرانك هوجرب قد توقع
بدقة زلزال تركيا وتحدث عن الدول
التي ستتأثر وقال ان الزلزال
سيحدث بقوة سبعة فاصل خمسة درجة
في منطقة جنوب وسط تركيا والاردن
وسوريا ولبنان. ولكن لم له احد
لتحل الكارثة. الدول المتوقعة
للزلازل. عربيا الخبير الهولندي
فرانكو جربيرتس الذي توقع زلزال
تركيا قبل حدوثه بثلاثة ايام ظهر
مجددا في مقابلة تليفزيونية
متوقعا لاستمرار الهزات
الارتدادية لايام او اسابيع في
سوريا ولبنان. اما مديرة المركز
الوطني للجيوفيزياء مارلينال
بريكس اكدت انه يمكن حصل زلزال
في لبنان بقوة زلزال تركيا ولا
يمكن توقعه في الايام او الاشهر
القادمة تركيا والجزائر والمغرب
هي من اكثر الدول عرضة للزلازل
حسب الخبير الجيولوجي يحيى
القزاز الذي توقع ايضا تكرار
الزلزال بشكل دوري في هذه
المناطق لانها ضمن حزام زلزالي.
ليشير المعهد الجيولوجي
البريطاني وكذلك المعهد الامريكي
الى ثلاثة احزمة فيها معظم
الزلازل ويتوقع ان تضربها
الزلازل مرة اخرى ولنبدأ
بالمنطقة الاولى. الحزام الناري
او ما تسمى بحلقة النار على حافة
المحيط الهادئ وتحدث فيها اكثر
من ثمانين في المائة من الزلازل
نتيجة الحركة التكتونية المستمرة
للصفائح في هذه المنطقة. يمتد
هذا الحزام من تشيلي شمالا على
طول ساحل المحيط الهادئ الى
المكسيك في امريكا الشمالية
مرورا بالساحل الغربي للولايات
المتحدة الى الاجزاء الجنوبية من
الاسكا. ويمتد ليشمل جزر الوتيان
في المحيط الهادئ واليابان
والفلبين وغينيا الجديدة وجزر
جنوب غرب المحيط الهادئ
ونيوزيلاندا بحسب وولد اطلس.
المنطقة الثانية الحزام الالبي.
يقع في منطقة تمتد لاكثر من خمسة
عشر الف كيلو من جاوا وسومطرة
نحو المحيط الاطلسي عبر شبه
جزيرة الهند الصينية. ويعبر جبال
الهيمالايا وجبال ايران والقوقاز
والاناضول والبحر الابيض
المتوسط. يمثل هذا الحزام حوالي
سبعة عشر في المائة من اكبر
الزلازل في العالم. وشهد اكثر
الزلازل تدميرا مثل زلزال
باكستان الذي اودى بحياة اكثر من
ثمانين الف شخص عام الفين وخمسة.
وزلزال اندونيسيا عام واربعة
الذي تسبب في حدوث كارثة تسونامي
المرعدة التي راح ضحيتها اكثر من
مائتين وثلاثين الف شخص. المنطقة
الثالثة حزام منتصف الاطلسي.
غالبا ما يحدث فيها تحت الماء
وبعيدا عن الاماكن الحضارية. لكن
ايسلندا التي تقع مباشرة فوق
منتصف المحيط الاطلسي تعرضت
لزلازل كبيرة بلغت درجتها اكثر
من ستة فاصل تسعة درجة. هذه
الاماكن الثلاثة هي ما يعرف
بالانشطة الزلزالية. لكن يمكن ان
تحدث الزلازل في اي منطقة خارج
هذه المناطق مثلما حدث في نيو
مدريد بولاية ميزر الامريكية في
عام الف وثمانمائة واحد عشر والف
وثمانمائة واثني عشر وتشارلستاون
في سانت كارولينا عام الف
وثمانمائة وستة وثمانين. ومع ذلك
عادة ما تنقضي سنوات عديدة بين
هذه الزلازل. والدول الخمس
الاكثر عرضة للزلازل في العالم
هي الصين واندونيسيا وايران
وتركيا واليابان وفق. هنا سيلفظ
هذا الفيديو انفاسه الاخيرة
معلنا عن نهايته. وقبل ان نضع
نقطة الختام ندعوكم للدعاء
للضحايا بالرحمة وللجرحى بالشفاء
العاجل.